We come together today before
all that we hold sacred,
and all that makes
us truly human,
and we ask for a blessing.
May we untie the
deep knots of racism.
May we unfurl a new
banner of freedom.
May we speak the truth
so boldly that we
shake the seats of power.
May we listen so bravely that
our own hearts are shaken free.
May we find strength in
community as we break bread
together And as we go
forth from this place
may we take hold of the
precious strands of history
that are our own lives,
so that together, we
may bend the arc of our
time closer and closer
to the great dream of justice.
Amen.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you for the blessing.
Thank you all for coming today.
I hope you've enjoyed
this morning's program.
It has been a
wonderful event, which
I hope has inspired you not only
to remember Dr. King's words,
but to act upon them.
Now we invite you to stay
for the delicious lunch.
[APPLAUSE]